The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: We established that,
essentially, what we want to do
is to describe the
properties of a system that
is in equilibrium.
And a system in equilibrium
is characterized
by a certain number
of parameters.
We discussed
displacement and forces
that are used for
mechanical properties.
We described how when systems
are in thermal equilibrium,
the exchange of heat requires
that there is temperature
that will be the
same between them.
So that was where the
Zeroth Law came and told us
that there is another
function of state.
Then, we saw that,
from the First Law,
there was energy, which is
another important function
of state.
And from the Second Law,
we arrived at entropy.
And then by
manipulating these, we
generated a whole set of
other functions, free energy,
enthalpy, Gibbs free energy, the
grand potential, and the list
goes on.
And when the system
is in equilibrium,
it has a well-defined
values of these quantities.
You go from one equilibrium
to another equilibrium,
and these quantities change.
But of course, we saw that the
number of degrees of freedom
that you have to
describe the system
is indicated through looking
at the changes in energy, which
if you were only
doing mechanical work,
you would write as sum over all
possible ways of introducing
mechanical work into the system.
Then, we saw that
it was actually
useful to separate
out the chemical work.
So we could also
write this as a sum
of an alpha chemical
potential number of particles.
But there was also
ways of changing
the energy of the system
through addition of heat.
And so ultimately,
we saw that if there
were n ways of doing
chemical and mechanical work,
and one way of introducing heat
into the system, essentially
n plus 1 variables are
sufficient to determine
where you are in
this phase space.
Once you have n
plus 1 of that list,
you can input, in
principle, determine others
as long as you have
not chosen things
that are really
dependent on each other.
So you have to choose
independent ones,
and we had some discussion
of how that comes into play.
So I said that today
we will briefly
conclude with the
last, or the Third Law.
This is the statement
about trying
to calculate the
behavior of entropy
as a function of temperature.
And in principle,
you can imagine
as a function of some coordinate
of your system-- capital X
could indicate pressure,
volume, anything.
You calculate that at
some particular value
of temperature, T, T the
difference in entropy
that you would have
between two points
parametrized by X1 and X2.
And in principle,
what you need to do
is to find some kind of a
path for changing parameters
from X1 to X2 and calculate,
in a reversible process, how
much heat you have to
put into the system.
Let's say at this fixed
temperature, T, divide by T. T
is not changing along the
process from say X1 to X2.
And this would be a
difference between the entropy
that you would have
between these two
quantities, between
these two points.
You could, in principle,
then repeat this process
at some lower temperature and
keep going all the way down
to 0 temperature.
What Nernst observed was that as
he went through this procedure
to lower and lower temperatures,
this difference-- Let's
call it delta s of T going
from X1 to X2 goes to 0.
So it looks like, certainly
at this temperature,
there is a change in entropy
going from one to another.
There's also a change.
This change gets
smaller and smaller
as if, when you get
to 0 temperature,
the value of your entropy is
independent of X. Whatever
X you choose, you'll have
the same value of entropy.
Now, that led to, after a while,
to a more ambitious version
statement of the Third Law
that I will write down,
which is that the entropy of
all substances at the zero
of thermodynamic temperature is
the same and can be set to 0.
Same universal
constant, set to 0.
It's, in principle,
through these integration
from one point to another
point, the only thing
that you can calculate is the
difference between entropies.
And essentially, this
suggests that the difference
between entropies goes to 0,
but let's be more ambitious
and say that even if you
look at different substances
and you go to 0 temperature,
all of them have a unique value.
And so there's more
evidence for being
able to do this for
different substances via what
is called allotropic state.
So for example, some materials
can exist potentially
in two different
crystalline states that
are called allotropes,
for example, sulfur
as a function of temperature.
If you lower it's
temperature very slowly,
it stays in some foreign all
the way down to 0 temperature.
So if you change its temperature
rapidly, it stays in one form
all the way to 0 temperature
in crystalline structure
that is called monoclinic.
If you cool it
very, very slowly,
there is a temperature
around 40 degrees Celsius
at which it makes a transition
to a different crystal
structure.
That is rhombohedral.
And the thing that
I am plotting here,
as a function of temperature,
is the heat capacity.
And so if you are, let's
say, around room temperature,
in principle you can say there's
two different forms of sulfur.
One of them is truly stable,
and the other is metastable.
That is, in principle, if
you rate what sufficiently
is of the order of
[? centuries ?],
you can get the transition from
this form to the stable form.
But for our purposes,
at room temperature,
you would say that
at the scale of times
that I'm observing things, there
are these 2 possible states
that are both equilibrium
states of the same substance.
Now using these two
equilibrium states,
I can start to test this
Nernst theorem generalized
to different substances.
If you, again, regard
these two different things
as different substances.
You could say that if I want
to calculate the entropy just
slightly above the transition,
I can come from two paths.
I can either come
from path number one.
Along path number
one, I would say
that the entropy at
this Tc plus is obtained
by integrating
degree heat capacity,
so integral dT Cx
of T divided by T.
This combination is
none other than dQ.
Basically, the combination
of heat capacity dT
is the amount of
heat that you have
to put the substance to
change its temperature.
And you do this all the
way from 0 to Tc plus.
Let's say we go
along this path that
corresponds to this
monoclinic way.
And I'm using this Cm that
corresponds to this as opposed
to 0 that corresponds to this.
Another thing that I can
do-- and I made a mistake
because what I really need
to do is to, in principle,
add to this some
entropy that I would
assign to this green state at 0
because this is the difference.
So this is the
entropy that I would
assign to the monoclinic
state at T close to 0.
Going along the
orange path, I would
say that S evaluated
at Tc plus is
obtained by integrating from 0.
Let's say to Tc
minus dT, the heat
capacity of this rhombic phase.
But when I get to just
below the transition,
I want to go to just
above the transition.
I have to actually be put in
certain amount of latent heat.
So here I have to add
latent heat L, always
at the temperatures Tc, to
gradually make the substance
transition from
one to the other.
So I have to add here L of Tc.
This would be the
integration of dQ,
but then I would have to add
the entropy that I would assign
to the orange state
at 0 temperature.
So this is something that
you can do experimentally.
You can evaluate at these
integrals, and what you'll find
is that these two
things are the same.
So this is yet
another justification
of this entropy
being independent
of where you start
at 0 temperature.
Again at this
point, if you like,
you can by [INAUDIBLE]
state that this
is 0 for everything
will start with 0.
So this is a supposed new
law of thermodynamics.
Is it useful?
What can we deduce from that?
So let's look at
the consequences.
First thing is so what
I have established
is that the limit
as T goes to 0 of S,
irrespective of whatever
set of parameters
I have-- so I pick T as one
of my n plus one coordinates,
and I put some other
bunch of coordinates here.
I take the limit
of this going to 0.
This becomes 0.
So that means, almost
by construction,
that if I take the derivative of
S with respect to any of these
coordinates-- if I take then
the limit as T goes to 0,
this would be
fixed T. This is 0.
Fine.
So basically, this
is another way
of stating that entropy
differences go through 0.
But it does have a consequence
because one thing that you will
frequently measure
are quantities,
such as extensivity.
What do I mean by that?
Let's pick a displacement.
Could be the length of a wire.
Could be the volume of a gas.
And we can ask if I were
to change temperature,
how does that quantity change?
So these are quantities
typically called alpha.
Actually, usually
you would also divide
by x to make them intensive
because otherwise x
being extensive,
the whole quantity
would have been extensive.
Let's say we do this at fixed
corresponding displacement.
So something that
is very relevant
is you take the volume of
gas who changes temperature
at fixed pressure, and
the volume of the gas
will shrink or expand
according to this extensive.
Now, this can be related to this
through Maxwell relationship.
So let's see what I have to do.
I have that dE is
something like Jdx plus,
according to what I
have over there, TdS.
I want to be able to write
a Maxwell relation that
relates a derivative of x.
So I want to make x
into a first derivative.
So I look at E minus Jx.
And this Jdx becomes minus xdJ.
But I want to take a derivative
of x with respect not
s, but with respect
to T. So I'll do that.
This becomes a minus SdT.
So now, I immediately see
that I will have a Maxwell
relation that says dx
by dT at constant J
is the same thing as
dS by dJ at constant T.
So this is the same thing by
the Maxwell relation as dS
by dJ at constant T. All right?
This is one of these quantities,
therefore, as T goes 0,
this goes to 0.
And therefore, the
expansivity should go to 0.
So any quantity that measures
expansion, contraction,
or some other change as a
function of temperature,
according to this law, as
you go through 0 temperature,
should go to 0.
There's one other quantity
that also goes to 0,
and that's the heat capacity.
So if I want to calculate the
difference between entropy
at some temperature T
and some temperature
at 0 along some particular
path corresponding
to some constant
x for example, you
would say that what
I need to do is
to integrate from 0 to
T the heat that I have
to put into the
system at constant x.
And so if I do
that slowly enough,
this heat I can write as CxdT.
Cx, potentially,
is a function of T.
Actually, since I'm indicating
T as the other point
of integration, let me call
the variable of integration T
prime.
So I take a path in which
I change temperature.
I calculate the heat
capacity at constant x.
Integrate it.
Multiply by dT to convert
it to T, and get the result.
So all of these results that
they have been formulating
suggest that the result that you
would get as a function of T,
for entropy, is something that
as T goes to 0, approaches 0.
So it should be a perfectly
nice, well-defined value
at any finite temperature.
Now, if you integrate
a constant divided
by T, divided by dT, then
essentially the constant
would give you a logarithm.
And the logarithm would blow
up as we go to 0 temperature.
So the only way that
this integral does not
blow up on you-- so this is
finite only if the limit as T
goes to 0 of the heat
capacities should also go to 0.
So any heat capacity should
also essentially vanish
as you go to lower
and lower temperature.
This is something that you
will see many, many times when
you look at different
heat capacities
in the rest of the course.
There is one other
aspect of this
that I will not really explain,
but you can go and look
at the notes or elsewhere, which
is that another consequence is
unattainability of T equals
to 0 by any finite set
of operations.
Essentially, if you want
to get to 0 temperature,
you'll have to do something
that cools you step by step.
And the steps become
smaller and smaller,
and you have to repeat
that many times.
But that is another consequence.
We'll leave that
for the time being.
I would like to, however, end
by discussing some distinctions
that are between
these different laws.
So if you think
about whatever could
be the microscopic
origin, after all, I
have emphasized
that thermodynamics
is a set of rules that you look
at substances as black boxes
and you try to deduce a
certain number of things
based on observations, such
as what Nernst did over here.
But you say, these
black boxes, I
know what is inside
them in principle.
It's composed of atoms,
molecules, light, quark,
whatever the
microscope theory is
that you want to assign to
the components of that box.
And I know the
dynamics that governs
these microscopic
degrees of freedom.
I should be able to get
the laws of thermodynamics
starting from the
microscopic laws.
Eventually, we will do
that, and as we do that,
we will find the origin
of these different laws.
Now, you won't be surprised
that the First Law is intimately
connected to the fact that
any microscopic set of rules
that you write down embodies
the conservation of energy.
And all you have to make
sure is to understand
precisely what heat is
as a form of energy.
And then if we regard heat
as another form of energy,
another component, it's
really the conservation law
that we have.
Then, you have the Zeroth
Law and the Second Law.
The Zeroth Law and Second Law
have to do with equilibrium
and being able to go in
some particular direction.
And that always runs a fall of
the microscopic laws of motion
that are typically things
that are time reversible where
as the Zeroth Law and
Second Law are not.
And what we will see later on,
through statistical mechanics,
is that the origin
of these laws is
that we are dealing with large
numbers of degrees of freedom.
And once we adapt the
proper perspective
to looking at properties
of large numbers of degrees
of freedom, which
will be a start
to do the elements of that
[? prescription ?] today,
the Zeroth Law and
Second Law emerge.
Now the Third Law, you
all know that once we
go through this process,
eventually for example,
we get things for the
description of entropy, which
is related to some
number of states
that the system
has indicated by g.
And if you then want to
have S going through 0,
you would require that
g goes to something
that is order of 1-- of 1 if
you like-- as T goes to 0.
And typically, you
would say that systems
adopt their ground state, lowest
energy state, at 0 temperature.
And so this is
somewhat a statement
about the uniqueness of the
state of all possible systems
at low temperature.
Now, if you think about
the gas in this room,
and let's imagine that
the particles of this gas
either don't interact, which is
maybe a little bit unrealistic,
but maybe repel each other.
So let's say you have
a bunch of particles
that just repel each other.
Then, there is
really no reason why,
as I go to lower and
lower temperatures,
the number of configurations of
the molecules should decrease.
All configurations that I
draw that they don't overlap
have roughly the same energy.
And indeed, if I look at say
any one of these properties,
like the expansivity of a
gas at constant pressure
which is given in fact
with a minus sign.
dV by dT at constant pressure
would be the analog of one
of these extensivities.
If I use the Ideal Gas
Law-- So for ideal gas,
we've seen that PV is
proportional to let's
say some temperature.
Then, dV by dT at
constant pressure
is none other than V over
T. So this would give me
1 over V, V over T. Probably
don't need it on this.
This is going to
give me 1 over T.
So not only doesn't it
go to 0 at 0 temperature,
if the Ideal Gas
Law was satisfied,
the extensivity would
actually diverge
at 0 temperature as
different as you want.
So clearly the Ideal Gas
Law, if it was applicable
all the way down
to 0 temperature,
would violate the Third
Law of thermodynamics.
Again, not surprising
given that I have told you
that a gas of classical
particles with repulsion
has many states.
Now, we will see
later on in the course
that once we include quantum
mechanics, then as you
go to 0 temperature,
these particles
will have a unique state.
If they are bosons, they will be
together in one wave function.
If they are fermions, they
will arrange themselves
appropriately so that,
because of quantum mechanics,
all of these laws would
certainly breakdown at T equals
to 0.
You will get 0 entropy, and
you would get consistency
with all of these things.
So somehow, the nature
of the Third Law
is different from the other
laws because its validity
rests on being able to
be living in a world
where quantum mechanics applies.
So in principle, you could have
imagined some other universe
where h-bar equals
to 0, and then
the Third Law of thermodynamics
would not hold there
whereas the Zeroth Law
and Second Law would hold.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are there any known
exceptions to the Third Law?
Are we going to
[? account for them? ?]
PROFESSOR: For
equilibrium-- So this
is actually an
interesting question.
What do I know
about-- classically,
I can certainly come up with
lots of examples that violate.
So your question then amounts if
I say that quantum mechanics is
necessary, do I
know that the ground
state of a quantum
mechanical system is unique.
And I don't know of a proof of
that for interacting system.
I don't know of a case that's
violated, but as far as I know,
there is no proof that I give
you an interacting Hamiltonian
for a quantum system, and
there's a unique ground state.
And I should say
that there'd be no--
and I'm sure you know of cases
where the ground state is not
unique like a ferromagnet.
But the point is not that
g should be exactly one,
but that the limit
of log g divided
by the number of
degrees of freedom
that you have should go to
0 as n goes to infinity.
So something like a ferromagnet
may have many ground states,
but the number of
ground states is not
proportional to the number of
sites, the number of spins,
and this entity will go to 0.
So all the cases that we
know, the ground state
is either unique
or is order of one.
But I don't know a theorem that
says that should be the case.
So this is the last
thing that I wanted
to say about thermodynamics.
Are there any
questions in general?
So I laid out the
necessity of having
some kind of a description of
microscopic degrees of freedom
that ultimately will
allow us to prove
the laws of thermodynamics.
And that will come through
statistical mechanics, which
as the name implies, has
to have certain amount
of statistic characters to it.
What does that mean?
It means that you have to
abandon a description of motion
that is fully
deterministic for one
that is based on probability.
Now, I could have told you
first the degrees of freedom
and what is the
description that we
need for them to
be probabilistic,
but I find it more
useful to first lay out
what the language
of probability is
that we will be
using and then bring
in the description of the
microscopic degrees of freedom
within this language.
So if we go first
with definitions--
and you could, for example, go
to the branch of mathematics
that deals with probability,
and you will encounter something
like this that what probability
describes is a random variable.
Let's call it X, which has a
number of possible outcomes,
which we put together
into a set of outcomes, S.
And this set can be discrete as
would be the case if you were
tossing a coin, and
the outcomes would
be either a head or a tail,
or we were throwing a dice,
and the outcomes would
be the faces 1 through 6.
And we will encounter
mostly actually cases
where S is continuous.
Like for example, if I want to
describe the velocity of a gas
particle in this room, I need
to specify the three components
of velocity that can
be anywhere, let's say,
in the range of real numbers.
And again, mathematicians
would say that to each event,
which is a subset of
possible outcomes,
is assigned a value which we
must satisfy the following
properties.
First thing is the
probability of anything
is a positive number.
And so this is positivity.
The second thing is additivity.
That is the probability
of two events, A or B,
is the sum total of
the probabilities
if A and B are
disjoint or distinct.
And finally, there's
a normalization.
That if you're event is
that something should happen
the entire set, the probability
that you assign to that is 1.
So these are formal statements.
And if you are a mathematician,
you start from there,
and you prove theorems.
But from our perspective,
the first question to ask
is how to determine this
quantity probability
that something should happen.
If it is useful and I want to do
something real world about it,
I should be able to measure
it or assign values to it.
And very roughly
again, in theory,
we can assign probabilities
two different ways.
One way is called objective.
And from the perspective
of us as physicists
corresponds to what would be
an experimental procedure.
And if it is assigning p of e
as the frequency of outcomes
in large number of
trials, i.e. you
would say that the probability
that event A is obtained
is the number of times you
would get outcome A divided
by the total number of
trials as n goes to infinity.
So for example, if you want to
assign a probability that when
you throw a dice that face 1
comes up, what you could do
is you could make a table
of the number of times
1 shows up divided by the number
of times you throw the dice.
Maybe you throw it 100
times, and you get 15.
You throw it 200
times, and you get--
that is probably too much.
Let's say 15-- you get 35.
And you do it 300 times, and
you get something close to 48.
The ratio of these
things, as the number
gets larger and
larger, hopefully
will converge to something that
you would call the probability.
Now, it turns out that
in statistical physics,
we will assign things through
a totally different procedure
which is subjective.
If you like, it's
more theoretical,
which is based on uncertainty
among all outcomes.
Because if I were to
subjectively assign
to throwing the dice and
coming up with value of 1,
I would say, well, there's six
possible faces for the dice.
I don't know anything about
this dice being loaded,
so I will say they
are all equally alike.
Now, that may or may not
be a correct assumption.
You could test it.
You could maybe
throw it many times.
You will find that either the
dice is loaded or not loaded
and this is correct or not.
But you begin by
making this assumption.
And this is actually, we
will see later on, exactly
the type of assumption
that you would
be making in
statistical physics.
Any question about
these definitions?
So let's again
proceed slowly to get
some definitions established by
looking at one random variable.
So this is the next section
on one random variable.
And I will assume that
I'll look at the case
of the continuous
random variable.
So x can be any real number
minus infinity to infinity.
Now, a number of definitions.
I will use the term
Cumulative-- make
sure I'll use the-- Cumulative
Probability Function, CPF,
that for this one
random variable,
I will indicate
by capital P of x.
And the meaning of
this is that capital P
of x is the probability
of outcome less than x.
So generically,
we say that x can
take all values
along the real line.
And there is this
function that I
want to plot that I will
call big P of x Now big P
of x is a probability,
therefore,
it has to be positive according
to the first item that we
have over there.
And it will be less than 1
because the net probability
for everything toward
here is equal to 1.
So asymptotically,
where I go all the way
to infinity, the
probability that I
will get some number along the
line-- I have to get something,
so it should automatically
go to 1 here.
And every element of
probability is positive,
so it's a function that
should gradually go down.
And presumably, it
will behave something
like this generically.
Once we have the Cumulative
Probability Function,
we can immediately construct the
Probability Density Function,
PDF, which is the
derivative of the above.
P of x is the derivative of big
P of x with respect to the x.
And so if I just take here
the curve that I have above
and take its derivative,
the derivative
will look something like this.
Essentially, clearly by the
definition of the derivative,
this quantity is
therefore ability
of outcome in the
interval x to x plus dx
divided by the size
of the interval dx.
couple of things to
remind you of, one of them
is that the Cumulative
Probability is a probability.
It's a dimensionless
number between 0 and 1.
Probability Density is obtained
by taking a derivative,
so it has dimensions that are
inverse of whatever this x is.
So if I change my variable
from meters to centimeters,
let's say, the value
of this function
would change by a factor of 100.
And secondly, while
the Probability Density
is positive, its
value is not bounded.
It can be anywhere
that you like.
One other, again,
minor definition
is expectation value.
So I can pick some
function of x.
This could be x itself.
It could be x squared.
It could be sine x, x
cubed minus x squared.
The expectation value
of this is defined
by integrating the
Probability Density
against the value
of the function.
So essentially,
what that says is
that if I pick some
function of x-- function
can be positive,
negative, et cetera.
So maybe I have a function
such as this-- then the value
of x is random.
If x is in this
interval, this would
be the corresponding
contribution to f of x.
And I have to look at
all possible values of x.
Question?
Now, very associated to this
is a change of variables.
You would say that if x is
random, then f of x is random.
So if I ask you what is
the value of x squared,
and for one random
variable, I get this.
The value of x
squared would be this.
If I get this, the
value of x squared
would be something else.
So if x is random, f of x
is itself a random variable.
So f of x is a random
variable, and you
can ask what is the
probability, let's
say, the Probability Density
Function that I would associate
with the value of this.
Let's say what's the
probability that I will find it
in the interval between
small f and small f plus df.
This will be Pf f of f.
You would say that the
probability that I would find
the value of the function
that is in this interval
corresponds to finding a value
of x that is in this interval.
So what I can do,
the probability
that I find the value
of f in this interval,
according to what I have here,
is the Probability Density
multiplied by df.
Is there a question?
No.
So the probability that
I'm in this interval
translates to the probability
that I'm in this interval.
So that's probability p of x dx.
But that's boring.
I want to look at the
situation maybe where
the function is
something like this.
Then, you say that f is
in this interval provided
that x is either
here or here or here.
So what I really need
to do is to solve
f of x equals to f for x.
And maybe there
will be solutions
that will be x1,
x2, x3, et cetera.
And what I need to
do is to sum over
the contributions of
all of those solutions.
So here, it's three solutions.
Then, you would say
the Probability Density
is the sum over i P
of xi, the xi by df,
which is really the slopes.
The slopes translate the
size of this interval
to the size of that interval.
You can see that here,
the slope is very sharp.
The size of this
interval is small.
It could be wider
accordingly, so I
need to multiply by dxi by df.
So I have to multiply by
dx by df evaluated at xi.
That's essentially the value
of the derivative of f.
Now, sometimes, it is easy
to forget these things
that I write over here.
And you would say,
well obviously,
the probability of
something that is positive.
But without being careful,
it is easy to violate
such basic condition.
And I violated it here.
Anybody see where I violated it.
Yeah, the slope
here is positive.
The slope here is positive.
The slope here is negative.
So I am subtracting
a probability here.
So what I really
should do-- it really
doesn't matter whether the
slope is this way or that way.
I will pick up
the same interval,
so make sure you don't forget
the absolute values that
go accordingly.
So this is the
standard way that you
would make change of variables.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
In the center of that board,
on the second line, it says Pf.
Is that an x or a times?
PROFESSOR: In the
center of this board?
This one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So the
value of the function
is a random variable, right?
It can come up to be here.
And so there is, as any other
one parameter random variable,
a Probability Density
associated with that.
That Probability Density
I have called P of f
to indicate that
it is the variable
f that I'm
considering as opposed
to what I wrote
originally that was
associated with the value of x.
AUDIENCE: But what you have
written on the left-hand side,
it looks like your
x [? is random. ?]
PROFESSOR: Oh, this was
supposed to be a multiplication
sign, so sorry.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: CP-- that function,
is this [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So you're asking whether this--
so I constructed something,
and my statement is that the
integral from minus infinity
to infinity df Pf of f better be
one which is the normalization.
So if you're asking
about this, essentially,
you would say the
integral dx p of x
is the integral dx
dP by dx, right?
That was the definition p of x.
And the integral
of the derivative
is the value of the function
evaluated at its two extremes.
And this is one minus 0.
So by construction, it
is, of course, normalized
in this fashion.
Is that what you were asking?
AUDIENCE: I was asking
about the first possibility
of cumulative
probability function.
PROFESSOR: So the
cumulative probability,
its constraint is that
the limit as its variable
goes to infinity,
it should go to 1.
That's the normalization.
The normalization here
is that the probability
of the entire set is 1.
Cumulative adds
the probabilities
to be anywhere up to point x.
So I have achieved being
anywhere on the line
by going through this point.
But certainly, the integral
of P of xdx is not equal to 1
if that's what you're asking.
The integral of
small p of x is 1.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are we assuming
the function is invertible?
PROFESSOR: Well, rigorously
speaking, this function
is not invertible
because for a value of f,
there are three
possible values of x.
So it's not a function,
but you can certainly
solve for f of x equals to
f to find particular values.
So again, maybe it
is useful to work
through one example of this.
So let's say that you
have a probability that
is of the form e to the minus
lambda absolute value of x.
So as a function of x,
the Probability Density
falls off exponentially
on both sides.
And again, I have to ensure that
when I integrate this from 0
to infinity, I will get one.
The integral from
0 to infinity is
1 over lambda,
from minus infinity
to zero by symmetry
is 1 over lambda.
So it's really I have to divide
by 2 lambda-- to lambda over 2.
Sorry.
Now, suppose I change variables
to F, which is x squared.
So I want to know what
the probability is
for a particular value of x
squared that I will call f.
So then what I have to
do is to solve this.
And this will give me x is minus
plus square root of small f.
If I ask for what f of-- for
what value of x, x squared
equals to f, then I have
these two solutions.
So according to the
formula that I have,
I have to, first of
all, evaluate this
at these two possible routes.
In both cases, I will get
minus lambda square root of f.
Because of the absolute
value, both of them
will give you the same thing.
And then I have to look
at this derivative.
So if I look at this, I can
see that df by dx equals to 2x.
The locations that I have to
evaluate are at plus minus
square root of f.
So the value of the slope is
minus plus to square root of f.
And according to that
formula, what I have to do
is to put the inverse of that.
So I have to put for one
solution, 1 over 2 square root
of f.
For the other one, I have to
put 1 over minus 2 square root
of f, which would be a disaster
if I didn't convert this
to an absolute value.
And if I did convert that
to an absolute value,
what I would get is lambda
over 2 square root of f
e to the minus lambda root f.
It is important to note
that this solution will only
exist only if f is positive.
And there's no solution
if f is negative,
which means that if I
wanted to plot a Probability
Density for this
function f, which
is x squared as a function
of f, it will only
have values for positive
values of x squared.
There's nothing for
negative values.
For positive values,
I have this function
that's exponentially decays.
Yet at f equals to 0 diverges.
One reason I chose
that example is
to emphasize that these
Probability Density
functions can even go
all the way infinity.
The requirement,
however, is that you
should be able to integrate
across the infinity because
integrating across the infinity
should give you a finite number
less than 1.
And so the type of divergence
that you could have is limited.
1 over square root of f is fine.
1/f is not accepted.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I have a doubt
about [? the postulate. ?]
It says that if you raise
the value of f slowly,
you will eventually get to--
yeah, that point right there.
So if the prescription that
we have of summing over
the different roots, at
some point, the roots,
they converge.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So at some point,
we stop summing over 2
and we start summing over 1.
It just seems a
little bit strange.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
If you are up here, you have
only one term in the sum.
If you are down here,
you have three terms.
And that's really just
the property of the curve
that I have drawn.
And so over here, I
have only one root.
Over here, I have three roots.
And this is not surprising.
There are many situations
in mathematics or physics
where you encounter
situations where,
as you change some parameters,
new solutions, new roots,
appear.
And so if this was really some
kind of a physical system,
you would probably
encounter some kind
of a singularity of phase
transitions at this point.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: But how does the
equation deal with that when
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Let's see.
So if I am approaching
that point, what I find
is that the f by
the x goes to 0.
So the x by df has some kind
of infinity or singularity,
so we have to deal with that.
If you want, we can
choose a particular form
of that function and
see what happens.
But actually, we have
that already over here
because the function f
that I plotted for you
as a function of x
has this behavior
that, for some range of
f, you have two solutions.
So for negative values
of f, I have no solution.
So this curve, after
having rotated,
is precisely an example
of what is happening here.
And you see what the
consequence of that is.
The consequence of that
is that as I approach here
and the two solutions merge,
I have the singularity that
is ultimately
manifested in here.
So in principle, yes.
When you make these
changes of variables
and you have functions
that have multiple solution
behavior like that, you
have to worry about this.
Let me go down here.
One other definition
that, again, you've
probably seen, before
we go through something
that I hope you
haven't seen, moment.
A form of this expectation
value-- actually, here we
did with x squared,
but in general, we
can calculate the expectation
value of x to the m.
And sometimes, that is called
mth moment is the integral 0
to infinity dx x
to the m p of x.
Now, I expect that
after this point,
you would have seen everything.
But next one maybe
half of you have seen.
And the next item,
which we will use a lot,
is the characteristic function.
So given that I have some
probability distribution
p of x, I can calculate
various expectation values.
I calculate the expectation
value of e to the minus ikx.
This is, by definition
that you have,
I have to integrate
over the domain of x--
let's say from minus infinity
to infinity-- p of x against e
to the minus ikx.
And you say, well, what's
special about that?
I know that to be the
Fourier transform of p of x.
And it is true.
And you also know how to
invert the Fourier transform.
That is if you know the
characteristic function, which
is another name for the Fourier
transform of a probability
distribution, you
would get the p of x
back by the integral
over k divided by 2pi,
the way that I chose the things,
into the ikx p tilde of k.
Basically, this is the
standard relationship
between these objects.
So this is just a
Fourrier transform.
Now, something that appears a
lot in statistical calculations
and implicit in lots
of things that we
do in statistical mechanics
is a generating function.
I can take the characteristic
function p tilde of k.
It's a function of this
Fourrier variable, k.
And I can do an
expansion in that.
I can do the expansion
inside the expectation value
because e to the minus ikx I can
write as a sum over n running
from 0 to infinity minus ik
to the power of m divided by n
factorial x to the nth.
This is the expansion
of the exponential.
The variable here is x, so I can
take everything else outside.
And what I see is that
if I make an expansion
of the characteristic
function, the coefficient
of k to the n up to some
trivial factor of n factorial
will give me the nth moment.
That is once you have
calculated the Fourrier
transform, or the characteristic
function, you can expand it.
And you can, from out
of that expansion, you
can extract all the
moments essentially.
So this is expansion
generates for you the moments,
hence the generating function.
You could even do
something like this.
You could multiply e to the
ikx0 for some x0 p tilde of k.
And that would be the
expectation value of e
to the ikx minus x0.
And you can expand
that, and you would
generate all of the moments
not around the origin,
but around the point x0.
So simple manipulations of
the characteristic function
can shift and give you
other set of moments
around different points.
So the Fourier transform,
or characteristic function,
is the generator of moments.
An even more
important property is
possessed by the cumulant
generating function.
So you have the
characteristic function,
the Fourier transform.
You take its log, so
another function of k.
You start expanding this
function in covers of k.
Add the coefficients of
that, you call cumulants.
So I essentially repeated the
definition that I had up there.
I took a log, and all I did
is I put this subscript c
to go from moments to cumulants.
And also, I have to start the
series from 1 as opposed to 0.
And essentially, I can find the
relationship between cumulants
and moments by
writing this as a log
of the characteristic
function, which
is 1 plus some n
plus 1 to infinity
of minus ik to the n over n
factorial, the nth moments.
So inside the log,
I have the moments.
Outside the log, I
have the cumulants.
And if I have a log
of 1 plus epsilon,
I can use the expansion
of this as epsilon minus
epsilon squared over 2 epsilon
cubed over 3 minus epsilon
to the fourth over 4, et cetera.
And this will enable me to
then match powers of minus ik
on the left and powers
of minus ik on the right.
You can see that the first
thing that I will find
is that the expectation
value of x-- the first power,
the first term that I have
here is minus ik to the mean.
Take the log, I will get that.
So essentially, what I get
is that the first cumulant
on the left is the
first moment that I
will get from the
expansion on the right.
And this is, of course, called
the mean of the distribution.
The second cumulant, I will
have two contributions,
one from epsilon, the other from
minus epsilon squared over 2.
And If you go through
that, you will
get that it is expectation
value of x squared
minus the average of x,
the mean squared, which
is none other than the
expectation value of x
around the mean squared, which
is clearly a positive quantity.
And this is the variance.
And you can keep going.
The third cumulant is x cubed
minus 3 average of x squared
average of x plus 2
average of x itself cubed.
It is called the skewness.
I don't write the
formula for the next one
which is called
a [? cortosis ?].
And you keep going and so forth.
So it turns out that this
hierarchy of cumulants,
essentially, is a hierarchy
of the most important things
that you can know about
a random variable.
So if I tell you that the
outcome of some experiment
is some number x,
distribute it somehow-- I
guess the first thing that
you would like to know
is whether the typical
values that you get
are of the order of 1, are of
the order of million, whatever.
So somehow, the
mean is something
that tells you something that is
most important is zeroth order
thing that you want to
know about the variable.
But the next thing that
you might want to know
is, well, what's the spread?
How far does this thing go?
And then the variance will tell
you something about the spread.
So the next thing
that you want to do
is maybe if given
the spread, am I
more likely to get things
that are on one side or things
that are on the other side.
So the measure of its
asymmetry, right versus left,
is provided by the third
cumulant, which is the skewness
and so forth.
So typically, the
very first few members
of this hierarchy of
cumulants tells you
the most important
information that you
need about the probability.
Now, I will mention
to you, and I
guess we probably will deal
with it more next time around,
the result that is in some
sense the backbone or granddaddy
of all graphical expansions
that are carrying [INAUDIBLE].
And that's a relationship
between the moments
and cumulants that I
will express graphically.
So this is graphical
representation
of moments in
terms of cumulants.
Essentially, what I'm
saying is that you
can go through the
procedure as I outlined.
And if you want to calculate
minus ik to the fifth power
so that you find the description
of the fifth cumulant in terms
of the moment, you'll
have to do a lot of work
in expanding the log and powers
of this object and making sure
that you don't make any
mistakes in the coefficient.
There is a way to
circumvent that graphically
and get the relationship.
So how do we do that?
You'll represent nth cumulant
as let's say a bag of endpoints.
So let's say this entity will
represent the third cumulant.
It's a bag with three points.
This-- one, two, three,
four, five, six--
will represent the
sixth cumulant.
Then, the nth moment
is some of all ways
of distributing end
points amongst bags.
So what do I mean?
So I want to calculate
the first moment x.
That would correspond
to one point.
And really, there's
only one diagram
I can put the bag
around it or not
that would correspond to this.
And that corresponds
to the first cumulant,
basically rewriting
what I had before.
If I want to look at the second
moment, the second moment
I need two points.
The two points I can either
put in the same bag or I
can put into two separate bags.
And the first one
corresponds to calculating
the second cumulant.
The second term
corresponds to two ways
in which their first
cumulant has appeared,
so I have to squared x.
if I want to calculate the
third moment, I need three dots.
The three dots I can
either put in one bag
or I can take one of them out
and keep two of them in a bag.
And here I had the
choice of three things
that I could've pulled out.
Or, I could have all of them in
individual bags of their own.
And mathematically, the first
term corresponds to x cubed c.
The third term corresponds
to three versions
of the variance times the mean.
And the last term is
just the mean cubed.
And you can massage
this expression
to see that I get the expression
that I have for the skewness.
I didn't offhand
remember the relationship
that I have to write down
for the fourth cumulant.
But I can graphically,
immediately get
the relationship for
the fourth moment
in terms of the fourth
cumulant which is this entity.
Or, four ways that I
can take one of the back
and maintain three in the bag,
three ways in which I have
two bags of two, six ways in
which I can have a bag of two
and two things that are
individually apart, and one
way in which there
are four things that
are independent of each other.
And this becomes x to the fourth
cumulant, the fourth cumulant,
4 times the third
cumulant times the mean,
3 times the square
of the variance,
6 times the variance
multiplied by the mean squared,
and the mean raised
to the fourth power.
And you can keep going.
AUDIENCE: Is the variance not
squared in the third term?
PROFESSOR: Did I forget that?
Yes, thank you.
All right.
So the proof of this is really
just the two-line algebra
exponentiating these expressions
that we have over here.
But it's much nicer to
represent that graphically.
And so now you can go
between things very easily.
And what I will show next time
is how, using this machinery,
you can calculate any
moment of a Gaussian,
for example, in just a
matter of seconds as opposed
to having to do integrations
and things like that.
So that's what we
will do next time will
be to apply this machinery
to various probability
distribution, such
as a Gaussian,
that we are likely to
encounter again and again.